on les voit de plus en plus dans les
rues dans les commerces japon tout le
temps des marchés publics quand tu peux
que respecter ça a été le débat ce matin
là uniquement à me demander si je mets
tellement ce que si je m'étais pas le
masque puis quand je l'essayé dans le
fond de tomber un du visage fois que je
me rendais compte que cinq dernières
années parce que ma mère ont fait et je
dois le recevoir dans la semaine
il est expédié de france donc voilà
j'attends juste qu'il arrive et les
masques artisanaux sont aussi de plus en
plus en demande dans cette épicerie de
quartier à montréal le port du masque
est fortement suggérée n'est pas
obligatoire ni pour les clients ni pour
les employés on est un peu comme le
gouvernement on essaie de lire les plus
par là l'éducation que par la force donc
les gens déjà se répondent bien je pense
parce que le sujet du port du masque
revient constamment quand vous sortez de
chez vous mettez vous un mas on ça va
faire partie de la nouvelle étiquette
respiratoires
faut d'abord qu'une disponibilité avant
de rendre quelque chose d'obligatoire un
million de masques qu'une chose 10
millions de masques c'est pas mal plus
compliqué mais quand et où exactement
devrions-nous le porter je pense la
façon la plus simple d'approché le port
du masque c'est de se dire qu'on doit le
porter en tout temps quand on sort de la
maison partout même dans les parcs en
vélo et en faisant son jogging selon la
docteure cécile trambly question de bié
l'intégrer dans nos habitudes de vie
avait le nom pourquoi les gens voient
pas l'intérêt
moi je pense que s'ils rendent
obligatoire je pense que c'est très
utile mais faudrait que tout le monde le
porte en championnat depuis je me
donneront des gens l'endroit où il est
toutefois primordial demeure le
transport en commun et si un endroit où
on doit le plus être attente s'est fait
porter le masque dans les transports en
commun mais là aussi il y en a qui le
porte
d'autres pas issigeac audrey charbonneau
raid au canada mon frère